la one humains voient en moyenne ces
premières rides à 30 ans ses premiers
cheveux blancs 38 pour enfin mourir
autour des 80 ans
pour de nombreux animaux ça ne se passe
pas comme ça la vieillesse la maladie ou
la mort sont des notions qu'ils ne
connaissent pas alors qui sont ces
animaux comme en font leur corps pour
surpasser ses problèmes et surtout
arriverons-nous un jour à reproduire ça
sur l'homme vous allez voir la clé
d'immortalité est déjà très probablement
dans la nature
pourra-t-on guérir le cancer grâce aux
animaux le cancer c'est la première
cause de décès prématuré en france et
elle représente environ 40% des décès
dans cette tranche d'âge
encore plus important que les accidents
de la route pour espérer repousser les
limites de la mort il est capital
d'éradiquer cette maladie
contrairement à une idée reçue le cancer
n'est pas seulement dû à l'alimentation
ou à la pollution les animaux peuvent
manger autant de verdure et le psy qui
veulent ils sont toujours soumis au
soleil au virus cancérigènes comme le
papillomavirus ou tout simplement des
erreurs naturel de duplication et de
stockage de l'adn impossible d'éviter le
cancer
sauf pour certains animaux qui ont
trouvé une petite parade
le premier c'est le rates obtenu mouais
malgré un look pas ouf
il est un miracle de la nature durée de
vie d'un rongeur normale entre 1 et 6
ans durée de vie d'un râteau tenue 32
ans en équivalent humain ça serait comme
si nous pouvions vivre 800 ans
en 800 ans il ya quand même le temps de
choper un ou deux cancers mais pas pour
lui ils sont capables d'isoler les
tumeurs dans leur organisme
je m'explique chacune de leurs cellules
et séparée de ses voisines par une
couche gluante d'acide hyaluronique
ainsi impossible qu'une cellule malade
contamine sa voisine
impossible de s'agglutiner en tumeurs
c'est une bonne piste mais il ya quand
même un défaut le râteau tenue ne
supprime pas les cellules cancéreuses
ils les isole juste il suffit juste
d'une baisse de production d'acide
hyaluronique pour que les tumeurs
s'activent
non si on veut vraiment lutter contre le
cancer il faut plutôt regarder du côté
de nos amis les éléphants probablement
le boss final de la lutte contre le
cancer
ça ne devrait pourtant pas être le cas
un éléphant possède deux cent mille fois
plus de cellules qu'un rat un
mathématiquement ses chances d'avoir une
cellule cancéreuse devraient être
multipliées en conséquence eh bien non
c'est ce qu'on appelle le paradoxe de
beto en réalité avoir beaucoup de
cellules paradoxalement sa baisse des
chances d'avoir un cancer
pourquoi grâce à la sélection naturelle
il ya une époque où plein de gros
animaux avait plein de cancer ce qui
fait qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps de se
reproduire
il ya eu sélection il n'existe
aujourd'hui que les organismes qui ont
développé des défenses contre la maladie
les éléphants sont le plus bel exemple
de ce paradoxe de paie tôt alors que
nous possédons qu'une seule copie du
gène p53 l'éléphant en possède 20 ce
gène serap détecter et supprimer les
cellules dont l'adn a été endommagée ce
qui évite le développement de tumeurs
le fait d'en avoir 20 copies laurent
hyper sensible à ça le problème du gène
p53 c'est qu'il devient inutile lorsque
la cellule s'est déjà transformées en
cellules cancéreuses or il existe
forcément des mutations que le gène p53
ne détecte pas c'est là qu'intervient la
deuxième ligne de défense de l'éléphant
le gène leaf 6 chez l'être humain et la
plupart des animaux le gène lip6 est
inactif c'est un vieux viennent de nos
ancêtres lointains qui ne sert plus à
rien mais chez les éléphants il s'est
réactivé il se trouve qu'il est
sacrément puissance eugène dès qu'il
détecte une cellule d sidente il monte
une équipe de protéines soldats et il
s'en va le régler son compte
les protéines vont trouver la
mitochondrie de la cellule malade ce qui
va couper sa source d'énergie et par ses
l'apoptose alors faut-il réactive ellip6
chez l'homme parce que si ça a été
désactivé c'est qu'il y a peut-être une
raison et surtout comment réactiver cela
ce nom en études genre génétiquement les
humains piquée 1 et j'ai pas trouvé de
réponse scientifique
la piste la plus accessible c'est
finalement celle du rat taupe et l'acide
hyaluronique étant déjà massivement
utilisés dans les traitements contre le
vieillissement en espérant en tout cas
que ça nous transcende pas en cette
chose pourra-t-on un jour arrêter de
vieillir grâce au homard y at il une
quête plus mythiques dans l'histoire de
l'humanité que la recherche de la
jeunesse éternelle and animals semble
l'avoir trouvé le homard à omar ne
vieillit pas toute sa vie
ces cellules vont rester jeune dès que
son corps est trop vieux il va muer et
devenir à omar tout neuf
si le muc c'est aussi parce que nous ne
s'arrête jamais de grandir là où un
humain stoppe sa croissance autour des
saisons le homard n'a pas de taille
biologique maximale techniquement un
homard 2000 ans pourrait avoir la taille
d'une voiture sauf que voilà on n'a
jamais vu de homard immortal de cette
taille
alors qu'est ce qui se passe on sait
qu'un homard dans la nature vit en
moyenne une cinquantaine d'années les
deux plus vieux on m'a reconnu s'appelle
georges et louis ils étaient en
captivité dans des aquariums de
restaurant et on estime leur âge à plus
de 140 en arriver à cette conclusion
était difficile car c'est presque
impossible de connaître l'âge d'un
homard celui-ci muant sa carapace son
système digestif
il ne reste pas grand chose de son
ancien lui si ce n'est l'accumulation de
graisse dans ses yeux plus la grèce plus
les vieux comme ça que les scientifiques
savent faire des estimations précises le
homard meurent généralement de causes
externes l'apej prédateurs ou les
maladies mais du coup je sais ce que
vous vous dites les homards des
aquariums de tout à l'heure
techniquement peuvent pas mourir du coup
alors déjà c'est sous pression des
organisations de protection des animaux
les deux homards ont finalement été
relâchés dans la nature donc oui ils
vont mourir maintenant même aux petits
soins un homard n'est pas immortel plus
gros si plus est bien difficile pour lui
d'avoir un exosquelette solide il finira
par mourir d'épuisement sa carapace lui
demandant trop d'énergie pour être
portés et générer c'est triste mais pour
nous humains c'est pas un problème
on sait très bien réguler nos hormones
de croissance qui plus est muet on sait
le faire aussi toutes les cellules de
nos corps change continuellement la
personne tout de suite et il ya dix ans
n'est plus la même qu'aujourd'hui alors
pourquoi n'at-on pas comme des homards
et bien à cause de la sénescence
laissez moi vous expliquer prenons une
de vos cellules de la peau par exemple
tout au long de sa vie cette cellule va
se diviser
par division entendait que son adn se
dédouble pour se protéger l'adn sous
forme de chromosomes possède à ses
extrémités ce qu'on appelle des
télomères voyez ça comme des boucliers
qui perd des points de vie à chaque coup
d'épée au bout de cinquante coups soit
50 divisions cellulaires ils deviennent
inefficaces
on appelle ça la limite de explique que
les télomères se raccourcissent et plus
la cellule est susceptible d'arrêter de
se dédoubler pour entrer en état de ces
naissances c'est un peu l'horloge
biologique de nos cellules
un tic-tac inarrêtable
leur mort le problème c'est que quand
ces cellules deviennent sénescentes elle
sécrète des molécules inflammatoires
nocives
ce qui contaminent des cils voisine et
provoque plein de problèmes de santé
vous êtes devenu vieux quoi le homard
lui possède la capacité de régénérer ces
télomères son adn à des points de vie à
l'infini la magie opère grâce à une
enzyme la télomérase
elle permet aux télomères de se reformer
après une division cellulaire et donc de
rajeunir nous humains nous avons sept
télomérase mais elle se limite à
certaines couches de la peau et aux
cellules souches
si nous arrivions les activés pour
l'ensemble de notre corps nous pourrions
arrêter de vieillir c'est sur quoi plein
de chercheurs travaille en ce moment et
il semblerait qu'on arrive à le faire
sur des souris peut-être que d'ici une
cinquantaine d'années l'homme aussi aura
un peu de homard en lui pourra-t-on un
jour rajeuni elle grâce aux méduses oui
oui vous avez bien entendu turritopsis
nutricula ou turritopsis dorny sont
capable de rajeunir même de revenir à
l'état de bébé on pourrait schématiser
le cycle de vie de cette méduse comme ça
une petite graine qui devient un polype
une sorte de truc qui ressemble n plus
lente
ça pousse ça pousse jusqu'à donner ça
des grappes de médias qui finissent par
se détacher grossir et vous piquez
pendant vos baignades estivales
turritopsis nutricula elle est capable
de redevenir un polype quand elle est
trop vieille qu'elle est stressé ou
qu'elles manquent de nourriture au
moindre souci europe
on commence le cycle mais quelle est la
sorcellerie capable de faire ça et bien
tout s'explique par un mot la
transdifférenciation grosso modo c'est
la capacité de 7000 juste de transformer
une cellule de tentacules en une autre
cellule un organe sensoriel par exemple
une méduse adulte peut alors revenir en
arrière dans ses divisions et trans
différencier tout ces cellules qui
constituent son corps pour former un
nouvel organisme un état de polypes en
revanche des scientifiques cherchent à
éclaircir certains points
déjà on ne sait pas exactement comment
la méduse est capable de cette prouesse
biologique suite on sait que la méduse
ne possède pas de cerveau à proprement
parler pourtant elle est capable
d'apprendre cartel alors la mémoire de
sa vie précédente
personne ne le sait réellement une chose
dont on est presque sûr en revanche
c'est que cette méduse est capable de
répéter ce processus autant de fois
qu'elle le veut ça en ferait alors le
premier organisme biologiquement
immortel si la méduse est capable de
rajeunir
alors pourquoi pas nous alors peut-être
pas revenir un embryon mais on pourrait
s'arrêter quand on était un enfant par
exemple ça serait cool eh bien
figurez-vous que nous avons cette
capacité il nous suffit juste d'activer
kahn gêne pour que la magie opère
on les appelle les facteurs yamanaka ces
quatre jeunes sont la clé de
l'immortalité de nos cellules
ils sont naturellement activé quand on
est un embryon dans le ventre de nos
mères mais lorsque nos cellules
deviennent adultes elles perdent leur
faculté à donner tous types de cellules
elles se choisissent un job et elle le
gardent toute leur vie ils gênent
yamanaka permettra à nos cellules de
peau ou des yeux de revenir des cellules
souches pluripotentes
c'est à dire à terme de reformer
n'importe quel type de cellules sans
arrêter de se diviser le problème de
cette machine à remonter dans le temps
c'est qu'on pousse les cellules assez
divisés indéfiniment or c'est exactement
ce que fait une tumeur sans oublier que
comme on l'a dit il ya une limite de
division à cause des télomères notre
corps s'autodétruire et c'est là que la
france entre en jeu nous sommes les
premiers à avoir réussi l'impensable
permettre à des cellules sénescentes de
retrouver leur jeunesse pour cela rien
de plus simple a ajouté seulement deux
autres gènes au cocktail de yamanaka est
ta dah les cellules reproduit faire
tranquillement puis retrouvent leur
pluripotence comme si rien n'était pas
de problème de thé le maire en plus la
télomérase est réactivée aussi ce qui
fait sauter la limite de division merci
les méduses alors que pensez vous de ce
voyage si excitant ou frontières de
l'immortalité humaine je sais que ce
débat mais souvent mal à l'aise
vous êtes à peu près tous d'accord pour
dire c'est important de mourir laisser
la place aux nouvelles générations
éviter la surpopulation mais bon la
réalité c'est qu'on a peur peur d'eux
pas être immortel parce qu'on ne sera
jamais assez riche pour s'offrir le
traitement ou juste néc trop tard pour
pouvoir en bénéficier
imaginez-vous seulement 1 90 ans voir
vos petits enfants devenir immortel et
vous tout ça parce que vous êtes trop
vieux pour que le traitement marche sur
vous ça semble horrible et c'est
exactement ce que notre génération
risque de vivre si on n'investit pas
plus d'efforts dans ses recherches
on est si proche du but et la nature
elle-même le permet alors pourquoi le
refuser je vous laisse en débattre en
commentaire un grand merci à skype pour
les recherches de la vidéo merci aussi à
toute l'équipe des monteurs pour leur
travail
allez les amis
[Musique]